et la lui donner. »
Mon père est atteint de dégénérescence lobaire fronto-temporale, ou DLFT.
C'est une maladie déroutante touchant les gens de 50 à 70 ans.
Elle peut complètement changer la personnalité des gens,
les rendre paranoïaques ou même violents.
Mon père en est atteint depuis 10 ans,
mais il y a trois ans, il est devenu vraiment malade
et nous avons dû le sortir de sa maison,
la maison où j'ai grandi,
celle qu'il a bâtie de ses propres mains.
Mon père, cool et costaud, qui chante d'une voix de fausset,
a dû déménager dans un centre de soins continus
à tout juste 65 ans.
Au début, ma mère, mes sœurs et moi avons commis l'erreur
de choisir une résidence pour aînés.
L'endroit était joli,
il y avait des tapis somptueux, des cours d'art l'après-midi
et un chien appelé Diane.
Puis j'ai reçu un appel.
« Mlle Malone, nous avons arrêté votre père.
- Quoi ?
- Il a menacé tout le monde avec des couverts.
Puis il a arraché les rideaux du mur
et tenté de lancer des plantes par la fenêtre.
Puis, il a sorti toutes les vieilles dames de leur fauteuil roulant.
- Toutes ?
(Rires)
Quel cowboy ! »
Après son expulsion,
nous l'avons trimbalé d'un centre public à l'autre
avant de trouver un centre de soins pour les personnes atteintes de démence.
Au début, ça lui plaisait plutôt
mais sa santé s'est dégradée.
Un jour, je suis entrée
et l'ai trouvé plié en deux à terre dans sa combinaison,
ce vêtement à fermeture éclair dans le dos.
Pendant une heure, je l'ai regardé tirer sur la combinaison,
essayer d'en sortir.
Et c'est censé être pratique,
mais ça m'évoquait plutôt une camisole de force.
Alors j'ai fui.
Je l'ai abandonné.
Je suis restée assise dans mon camion,
son vieux camion, pliée en deux,
un cri profondément enfoui, guttural sortait du creux de mon ventre.
Je n'arrivais pas à croire que mon père,
l'Adonis de mon enfance,
mon cher ami,
trouverait que cette vie-là valait encore la peine d'être vécue.
Nous sommes programmés pour valoriser la productivité.
Donc quand quelqu'un, ici, un Adonis,
n'est plus productif selon nos attentes envers lui,
selon ses attentes envers lui-même,
que vaut encore cette vie-là ?
Ce jour-là, dans le camion,
je ne pensais qu'à une chose : mon père était sous la torture
et son corps transportait cette torture.
Je devais le faire sortir de ce corps.
Je devais le faire sortir de ce corps. Je vais tuer mon père.
J'ai appelé ma sœur.
Elle m'a dit : « Beth,
tu ne veux pas vivre le reste de tes jours
en sachant que tu as tué ton père.
Et tu serais arrêtée, je crois,
car il ne peut pas l'accepter.
Tu ne sais même pas où acheter de l'héroïne. »
(Rires)
C'est vrai, je l'ignore.
En fait, nous parlons beaucoup de sa mort.
Quand surviendra-t-elle ? Comment ?
Si seulement nous en avions parlé quand nous étions tous en bonne santé.
À quoi ressemble ma meilleure mort ?
La vôtre ?
Mais ma famille n'a pas pensé à le faire.
Et ma sœur avait raison.
Je ne devrais pas tuer mon père à l'héroïne
mais je devais le faire sortir de ce corps.
J'ai consulté une voyante,
puis un prêtre et un groupe d'aide.
Ils m'ont tous dit la même chose :
parfois, les gens s'accrochent, inquiets pour leurs proches.
Dites-lui que vous allez bien et qu'il peut s'en aller s'il est prêt.
J'ai été voir mon père,
l'ai trouvé plié en deux à terre dans sa combinaison.
Il me regardait sans me voir ou fixait le sol.
Je lui ai donné un soda
et me suis mise à lui parler sans but précis
mais pendant que je parlais, il a éternué en buvant le soda
et son éternuement a légèrement redressé son corps,
lui insufflant un peu de vie.
Il a continué à boire, à éternuer et à reprendre vie
encore et encore, jusqu'à la fin.
Et j'ai entendu :
« Eheheheheh
eheheheheh ...
C'est merveilleux.
C'est merveilleux. »
Ses yeux étaient ouverts et il me regardait.
Je lui ai dit : « Bonjour papa. »
Et il a dit : « Salut Beth. »
Et j'ai ouvert la bouche pour lui dire...
« Papa, si tu veux mourir, tu peux.
Nous allons bien. »
Mais en ouvrant la bouche,
j'arrivais juste à dire : « Papa !
Tu me manques. »
Il a répondu : « Tu me manques aussi. »
Puis je me suis écroulée.
Je me suis écroulée et je me suis assise à côté de lui
car pour la première fois depuis longtemps,
il avait presque l'air bien.
Et j'ai gravé ses mains dans ma mémoire,
si reconnaissante que son esprit soit encore attaché à son corps.
À ce moment-là, j'ai compris
que je n'étais pas responsable de cette personne.
Je n'étais pas son médecin.
Ni sa mère.
Certainement pas son dieu.
Peut-être que la meilleure façon de nous aider, lui et moi,
était de reprendre nos rôles de père et de fille.
Alors nous sommes restés là,
assis calmement, comme nous l'avons toujours fait.
Personne n'était productif.
Nous avions encore de la force, tous les deux.
« Bon, papa, je vais y aller.
Mais on se voit demain.
- D'accord.
Dis,
cette hacienda est plutôt jolie. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)